[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen sli fällt
heute kleine törtchen und zwar mit blau
wärmebettchen oder heidelberg örtchen
pressen er überall anders blaubeeren
oder heidelberg
ich glaube aber er hat durch
heidelbeeren gekauft weiß ich das gleich
für wechsel in heidelberg mit johannes b
neo da wirklich aber dann kapierst du
mich kurz vor dem staub gemacht schallt
das gleiche wie brokkoli und blumenkohl
genau
naja egal ist ein anderes thema diese
törtchen sind wirklich super einfach
denn sie werden in der muffins gebacken
und der muffin wird dann gestürzt und
dann sieht es echt zu verhüten und vor
allem sehr edel aus und im innern hat
der schoko muffins noch eine frischkäse
heidelberg ein marken also so eine
füllung die aber eben auch mit gebacken
wird und daher hat man auch gar nicht so
viel arbeit also die sind wirklich
ruckzuck gemacht und sehr schnell fertig
ich sage euch mal die zutaten für die
füllung brauche ich 200 gramm glaube die
waren im tiefkühlfach 100 gramm
frischkäse im doppel raum stufe einen
viertel teelöffel backpulver 20 gramm
puderzucker und etwas manila extrakt für
die füllung verwende ich jetzt die
heidelbeeren die habe ich schon ein
bisschen antauen lassen die müssen gar
nicht mehr gefroren sein aber ich nehme
sie jetzt aus dem tiefkühlfach weil
jetzt gerade keine heidel weise so ist
so habe ich sie dann immer da dann der
frischkäse dazu ein bisschen butter
zucker und backpulver und vanille
extrakt und es ist einfach ganz kurz
verrühren
[Musik]
jetzt stelle ich die füllung zur seite
und zeigt euch mal die zutaten für die
muffins da nehme ich dann ganz normalen
muffins teig für den muffins zeit
brauche ich 150 gramm zucker eine prise
salz wenn viertel teelöffel natron einen
halben teelöffel backpulver 40 kompakt
160 gramm mehl jeweils 150 milliliter
sonnenblumenöl und butter match zweier
vanille extrakt um 30 gramm gehobelte
mandeln
der martinstag ist kein hexenwerk dafür
gebt ihr jetzt einfach alle trockenen
zutaten in einer schritte und die werden
jetzt kurz verrührt und da kommen jetzt
nur noch die flüssigen zutaten rhein und
dem ist jetzt auch noch ganz kurz
verrühren
das geht heute alles wunderbar schnell
jetzt nimmt hier eine muffin form und da
nehme ich jetzt keine papier förmchen
sondern fette thema in form ganz gut mit
etwas back trance prey und jetzt nehme
ich einen ice portionierer und fülle die
förmchen mit dem teig aber ich gebe
jetzt erst mal nur den halben tag rein
ist daher auch ein kleines funktionieren
[Musik]
und jetzt nehme ich dir eine überfüllung
und die kommt jetzt mitten rein
[Musik]
und jetzt kann ich die füllung mit dem
restlichen teig abdecken
[Musik]
und wer möchte kann jetzt noch die
mandeln drüberstreuen
[Musik]
und so kommen die muffins in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 180 grad ober
unterhitze und werden für 25 minuten
gebacken die muffins habe ich jetzt nach
dem backen zehn minuten abkühlen lassen
und jetzt habe ich so ein bisschen mit
den fingern gelöst und kann sie jetzt
auf eine abkühlung gitter stürzen und
dann komplett abkühlen lassen
[Musik]
die maschinen sind jetzt richtig gut
abgekühlt manche gingen jetzt besser
raus andere weniger falls ihr einen
muffin form habt ihr nicht so gut von
der beschichtung ist müsste sie auf
jeden fall fetten und mailen da kommen
sie nämlich ein bisschen besser aus aber
die waren jetzt echt schon richtig gut
jetzt mache ich die creme und auch den
blauen sirup und zeige euch mal die
zutaten für die creme brauche ich 200
gramm sahne 150 gramm mascarpone ihr
könnt aber auch frischkäse nehmen 30
gramm puderzucker etwas vanille extrakt
drei teelöffel sommerbad eine
unbehandelte limette und für den sirup
brauche ich hier nochmal 100 gramm
blaubeeren das sind die aus dem
tiefkühlfach und die sind bereits
aufgebaut und 30 kommen zucker werde ich
zuerst einmal die mieter nehmen und
davon die schale abreiben die kommt
nämlich in die creme und den saft
benutze ich dann für den zero und da ist
ganz wichtig dass es eine unbehandelte
limette ist und dass ihr nur den grünen
teil bleibt
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich auch schon mal den sirup
ansätzen der muss nämlich natürlich auch
abkühlen
da kommen jetzt die blaue beim rhein
gemeinsam mit dem saft wenig aufgefangen
habe dann zucker nach belieben also
gerne können dass ein bisschen süße oder
weniger machen und limettensaft und
blaubeeren und limetten die passen echt
gut zusammen sie können zwar eine
zitrone nehmen aber ich finde die meter
passt
das kann ich jetzt hier einfach
aufkochen lassen und ein paar minuten
köcheln lassen und kann jetzt hier in
der zeit schon mal die creme zubereitet
und dafür gibt die jetzt die sahne wenn
die rührschüssel also zur limettenschale
dazu da kommt die mascarpone mit rein
oder auch frischkäse ich mache drei das
ganz gerne puderzucker seiner partei und
vanille extrakt und dann kann ich die
creme einfach kurz steif schlagen
jetzt entsteht nur noch ganz kleine
bläschen dh die konsistenz ist perfekt
jetzt fühle ich das ganze um damit dass
jupp eben auch gut abkühlen kann
da stelle ich jetzt einfach kurz auf dem
kühlkette oder auf die terrasse wenn die
kalt ist und die creme habe ich bereits
in den spritzbeutel gefüllt mit einer
großen stern thüle und die kann ich
jetzt hier einfach drauf spritzen und
die cupcakes stelle ich dann noch kühl
bis der sirup auch abgekühlt ist
[Musik]
muratow dafür ihren ich habe jetzt
nämlich auf das sahnehäubchen einfach
noch die abgekühlte diese diesen sirup
drauf gegeben
und eben noch mit einem integriertem uhr
da die man schon was auf gewisse art
zwar ist für das video für die fotos
werde ich jetzt nicht gewesen ich hab
gehört ja angewiesen
doch damit du gleichzeitig was drinnen
ist einfach umdrehen können kann als
gemerkt freut sich die creme mit
heidelbeeren limette echte perfekte
kombi und wie findet es innen drin mit
der frucht füllung immer finden gut geld
voll sagte frank schmidt gleichzeitig
ich mag sie nicht mitmachen
ich dachte immer man kann bei muffins
eigentlich nichts falsch machen bis ich
mal einen auf einem schulfest gegessen
habe und ich hab's doch bekannt auch
viel falsch machen und selbst ausgehen
eine tolle idee zum mitbringen wenn man
zum beispiel irgendwo mal eingeladen ist
falls ihr das rezept nach machen möchtet
dann schaut auch sallys - blog.de vorbei
da steht noch mal alles ganz genau ich
wünsche euch einen guten appetit viel
spaß dann nachmachen und wir sehen uns
beim nächsten mal dann folgen besonderer
knapp
[Musik]